[Musique]
après 18 mois
on a vécu cette pandémie tout le monde
commence à se lasser un petit peu c'est
sûr que des mesures très contraignantes
vont peut-être être plus difficile et
c'est donc de faire en sorte que chacun
ayant bien connaissance du la
transmission du virus comment elle se
fait puisse agir de manière à limiter
cette transmission si une personne donc
est soumise à de l'air pollué
régulièrement son système respiratoire
est un petit peu affaibli et sa
indépendamment même de toutes
considérations liées à la présence ou
pas d'un virus on a pu aussi
s'apercevoir qu'il n'y a pas de deux
défaits systématique de portage dans de
transmission du virus plus importante en
présence de polluants dans cette
dynamique il ya un souci par rapport à
un enchaînement par rapport à la qualité
de l'air intérieur donc si la qualité de
l'air intérieur est dégradée faire
rentrer de l'oxygène c'est très bien en
revanche quand on fait rentrer de
l'oxygène venant de l'extérieur si
jamais vous avez un pic de pollution
extérieure et bien ce moment là vous
risquez de rentrer des facteurs qui
viendront affaiblir le système
respiratoire à des personnes qui sont à
l'intérieur et donc ce n'est pas
nécessairement une bonne chose il y
avait la nécessité d'avoir donc des
systèmes de ventilation performant
d'utiliser les rations à bon escient et
de 28 ans se poser la question de la
présence des capteurs de co2 mais aussi
des purificateurs d'air un capteur de
co2 qui est posée dans une pièce ne va
juste détecté que la quantité la
concentration de dioxyde de carbone dans
la pièce c'est un indicateur que les
gens respirent et ont expiré du co2 donc
on autant ciellement expiré des
gouttelettes et s'il ya une personne
infectée des gouttelettes qui
contiennent le virus
donc c'est un indicateur pour dire il
faut aérer il faut ventiler par exemple
dans une salle de classes de collège en
une heure on arrive à 2000 parties par
million la par là la concentration
moyenne dans les extérieurs c'est 400
parties par million une bonne qualité
ces 800 parties par millions dans une
pièce fermée donc c'est un indicateur il
faut très vite aéré
vous avez par exemple un purificateur
qui va qui vous est venu pour être
qu'une seule qui va dégrader certaines
molécules il faut pas oublier que la
dégradation de molécules dont la
naissance de nouvelles molécules et donc
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est si les
nouvelles molécules issues de la
dégradation des molécules de départ ne
sont pas elles aussi problématique est
donc tout ceci doit être encore démontré
il ya du travail encore à faire et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous pensons que
il ne faut pas écarter des solutions a
priori faut simplement au fur et à
mesure des solutions qui sont présentés
les étudier de manière dans des cadres
dans une situation dite réelle et faire
la preuve que ce à quoi le conduisent
vin ne permettra de 90,8 mendy pas une
autre forme de dégradation de la qualité
de l'air donc qui est traité par ce
système là
[Musique]